hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast excavating the deep
genome deciphering structural barish
variation in complex and repetitive
regions presented by Ryan emails
assistant professor Dept of
computational medicine and
bioinformatics assistant professor
Department of Human Genetics University
of Michigan I'm Alexis Clouse of
laberd's and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lappers laberd's is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen it's type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Mills I will now turn the presentation
over to him so hi everyone thanks for
attending this webinar on some of the
work we've been working on my lab so so
the last I said the title has talked as
they excavated the genome deciphering
structural variation and complex and
repetitive regions and I would like to
start my presentation was sort of the
mission statement of our lab we actually
have a departmental retreat a number of
years ago we're asked to put together a
sort of a mission statement and I like
this one and this is this idea that the
primary purpose of sequencing genomes is
to identify the underlying
genetic variation between individuals to
explore what role those changes have on
human phenotypes and in my laboratory
works in this arena and helps to develop
and implement methods to precisely
identify and resolve different types of
genomic variation with a strong focus on
structural genomic rearrangements and
you know our overall encompassing golus
integrate this information with other
forms that biologically and medically
relevant data to improve our overall
understanding of human health and
disease so when we talk genome variation
there's there's really there's different
ways you classify this but there's three
primary areas that these typically fall
into and the the most prevalent are
single nucleotide polymorphisms or snips
these are substitutions of one
nucleotide to another another classes
insertions and deletions polymorphism
these are small mutations that that
remove or add one or more nucleotides at
a particular locus and then there's
there's these larger structural
variation these are medium to large size
rearrangements of chromosomal DNA and
there's been quite a quite a lot of
effort in the last decade to dig into -
you know this the told you know
sequencing as a catalyst or
next-generation sequencing as a catalyst
to dig in and actually find this entire
repertoire of genetic variation from
large populations and and endeavor such
as a thousand genomes as really you know
pushed a lot of this ahead in terms of
both focus on small variants and and a
focus on large variants and the kind of
delineate these with a 50 base pair
cutoff Lewis that's quite arbitrary and
so many of these these projects you know
the thousand genomes completed about
five or so years ago and we now sort of
turned back retrospectively and we're
starting to look at this deep scale
variation discovery and there's a number
of current endeavors that are saying
instead of you know we spent time
looking at these large populations of
individuals and this has been very
fortuitous in terms of being able to
find
disease associations and then and you
know population specific differences but
now we're sort of looking
and maybe a smaller number of
individuals and figuring out what what
did we miss and are these are these
variants important and there's a lot of
different groups working on this I'm
highlighting to hear the genome in a
bottle group who has historically
focused on the smaller variants but are
currently branching out to look at the
larger variants as well and then sort of
the sequel to the thousand genomes
project there's a human genome
structural variation consortium that
still focus on large variants and I've
been fortunate to be part of this group
for over almost a decade now and you
know this this last there's a paper up
on the bye archive right now if you're
interested I'm not gonna really go into
much detail about this project I just
wanted to highlight that you know we're
digging into a you know small number of
trios with with lots of different
platforms to really dig into sort of the
full spectrum of genetic variation so if
you're interested in this area I would
suggest looking up the preprint and you
know of course mark and Ashley interests
upon the some of the leaders of this
project would be happy to answer
questions on that so before you go any
further I'd like to take a moment and
really define structure variation it's
one thing to say these large chromosome
rearrangements it's another to kind of
visualize what what what we mean by this
and you know this is a quote from NCBI
in terms of structural variation is
generally defined as a region of DNA 50
base pairs 41 KB but as I said we sort
of used 50 base 4 now larger in size and
keep alluding versions balanced
translocation genomic imbalances and so
forth and so just to visualize this we
take two individual chromosomes either
within an individual or between
individuals and you compare them to each
other and you'll see that some
individuals have parts of theirs that
chromosome that others don't and you
know depending on the perspective you're
looking at we could call this a deletion
this could also be a duplication event
where someone has two copies of a
particular region of a DNA cause to be
an insertion which again depending on
your respective to be deletion in one
sample or an insertion another
from another theirs inverted parts of
DNA where the orientation of a
chromosome our portion of a chromosome
is reversed and then translocation
events where pieces of DNA are moved to
other parts of the genome these last two
are sort of copying neutral events and
these these these first three categories
are typically which when you consider
when you hear a copy number variation
because you're actually changing that
the copy number in the DNA and so the
advent of next-generation sequencing has
really enabled us to be able to dig into
these types of rearrangements and I just
wanted to give a quick overview of how
many different tools utilize short
reading paired-end data to find these
and using deletions as an example here
what you find is that you know you
typicals
short reads sequencing you take a
fragment you sequence the end you line
them back to some sort of reference in
our case there's a reference genome that
the community uses and you have sort of
this expected distance between the reads
around deletions because the the piece
of DNA you're expecting in the genome
isn't there it actually lines further
apart than you would expect and so we
can use the signals of these expected
distances between these reads to infer
the location of different types of
structure variation we can also use read
depth where we we quantify the amount of
recover egde at different parts of the
genome and with the simple idea that if
you have less or more DNA at that at
that location then you're going to
observe more or less sequencing reads
that map there after a whole genome
experiment there's a split read
alignment and this is a special case
where an individual read is actually
sequenced across the big point of a
deletion and so on the sample you're
sequencing it's obvious it's naturally
continuous but when you line it back to
the reference it actually breaks in the
individual parts and then then you can
actually use that to many cases time
exact breakpoints and then there's
sequence assembly where you sort of use
the reads without knowledge of the
reference and you can assemble them back
into a
sequence align the reference of finding
separate points and of course I'm
simplifying this quite a bit but I
wanted to give an overview of this
because this becomes important when we
start thinking about what are the
limitations of these types of approaches
and the primary limitation is that
really many genomes and humans in
particular have high levels of
repetitive sequences right so humans
have o greater than 44% repetitive
content in our genome depending on how
you define that that value that can be
more or less and what this means is that
when you're my line will be short reads
back to a genome you often can't
distinguish between regions of identity
when they're aligned so example you
might have two repeats that are very
similar or may identical in your genome
and you you have one end of your read
that's anchored on two unique sequence
to the other end Maps inside this repeat
and so as you can see from this sort of
cartoon we don't really know where this
is mapping and it could be that this is
mapping canonically to this first repeat
are there may be some sort of deletion
that brings that second repeat into
proximity that first read and that would
be cryptic but we would not be able to
identify that because we cannot
distinguish between these these types of
events with short reads alone this
problem is compounded when both read map
within a repeat there's there are long
stretches of segmental duplications of
longer mobile element insertions that
where smaller fragment sizes of short
reads for example the typical 450 500
base pair of fragments of reads would
fall completely within this repeat and
then you have no anchor to even figure
out where on the genome or even which
chromosome you're on so this has been an
ongoing problem and one of the solutions
is sort of not really a solution at all
it's just to mask the repeats and just
just throw up our hands and say well we
can't find them and it's you know and
that's about all you can do to some
extent because it's the limitation of
the technology so you know the the last
number of years you know a number of
newer technologies have come out I think
most people are familiar with them to
say Biosystems smart valve technology
now these these consequence long reads
from one KB to
rarely but they can for up to 100 KB in
size individually they have high error
rate so ever you can do circulars and
since the sequencing and bring that
accuracy up quite a bit there are other
other long read technologies on the
horizon as well there's Oxford nanopore
technologies that just have recently had
a paper where they assembled a whole
genome with lift Oxford and of course so
that's that's up-and-coming as well but
this is 30 you know PacBio has been
around for a bit and has gotten quite
mature in terms of its aligners and its
processing in the lab and so we decided
to focus on this as an idea to figure
out sort of you know first off why are
we missing things and then what are we
missing and so the reason this works is
now you can go back to many of these
repeats and the lengths of these long
reads sort of traverse these sequences
and so now you know exactly which repeat
you're working with and in many cases
the the reads are longer than the
repeats and so you can find insertion of
those repeats so today I'm going to
really talk about two approaches that
our lab has developed to leverage the
continued continuity of these long reads
the first success as assess the accuracy
of short read SV colors and second to
identify previously overlooked variation
that fall within some of these
repetitive lesions oh this this first
project was done by a graduate in my lab
hong jiao she's currently a postdoctoral
fellow in the top hockey lab at MGH and
is also a one of the the a primary
contributor to the HTS VC paper I
mentioned earlier and so essentially one
of the things that we we have found in
this project is that so first off
there's lots of lines there's lots of SV
colors out there I know I lost track now
that it's probably in the 20 or 30 range
we we have one that we developed in our
own lab there there's many others that
have been developed that use different
combinations of repair knapping read
death split and so forth promises that a
lot of these aligners don't agree and
I'm not going to go into much depth on
this we talked about this in the buyer
five paper but there's quite a bit of
divergence and in what a particular
region is hollow and so you can example
take a region like this this is from a
high today deform mold that was
published by a benign fish group number
years ago see hm one so and what we see
here is a pattern so this is an ITV
screen shot and what you're basically
looking at here is these little grey
lines in the middle are canonically
aligned leads to a reference right so
these are read pairs that are aligned to
a reference that top panel is the
coverage around these regions and so
this is sort of a double haploid
sequence and so it's essentially a
haploid it's a single single haplotype
throughout the entire genome and so you
see it's either there's lots of sequence
or there's no sequence coverage the bond
so these green lines or reads that are
mapping in a reverse forward orientation
is this way and when you typically
expect reads to map and afford reverse
orientation and so this is indicative of
tandem duplications type signals and
then in red are reads that are mapping
further apart than you would expect and
so those are indicative of deletion type
of of regions in anise bottom panel we
have some long beach and so essentially
what you can do is you can look at this
and it's clear you can clearly segment
this region into individual blocks right
so you have this this first block that
has no read the second block that has a
normal amount of reads its third block
like a zero reads and just for just for
clarity sake we're gonna sign these into
these little arrow blocks with black
arrows at the end as anchors and what we
can do now is we can use these blocks
the sort of a dye to see how different
algorithms have have applied this and so
we ran three different colors on on this
region and what we basically find is
that one of the regions one of the
callers called a basically three
deletions you can see here that there's
no green arrow there's no blue arrow and
there's no other green arrow right and
then if furthermore those three
deletions and that orange arrow has move
before the purple arrow so that's
suggesting some sort of translocation
event ii sv color and you see it called
basically the same structure so again
you know representing that single
haplotype that we would expect in the
sample the second color you can see
actually called two different haplotype
structures including a very large tandem
duplication as well as a series of
deletions and then the third sv caller
called called a bunch of different
structures right and so and I'm you know
I'm not gonna go into it's none of them
this isn't about baking off different
algorithms versus each other but the
only outstanding question is which of
these is right right a priori without
knowing what the tree structure is how
would you know which of these algorithms
was really capturing the signals at this
location and so we spend a lot of time
looking at SV calls and one of the sort
of historical ways of looking at
structural variation is to use what's
called a dot plot or a recurrence but
this harkens back to the early 70s with
this idea that basically you take two
sequences and you line them up to each
other and you pick some sort of Kaymer
size right so maybe we'll pick a k-mer
of four or five here and you scan that
Kaymer
through the other sequence and whenever
you have an exact match you put a dot so
in this particular case we see as we
move through these sequences there are a
hundred percent identical at the
beginning and so we have this diagonal
line which is respective of identity
between the signals right and then here
we have a portion that's actually as a
subsequence a k-mer that's present in
another location on this sequence and so
we get two dots at that location of one
of the samples and only one on the other
and we can extend this off into the
entire structure and you get sort of
this this pattern here where these
sequences are identical to each other
but there's portions of these sequences
that are duplicated but they're
duplicated in each sequence so you can
imagine that if there is these sequences
were different and there was only one
duplication on one sample and not the
other then you would have this extra
line on the bottom and perhaps not at
the top
so we can use these these structures to
sort of look at using long reads look at
regions of a sample against a reference
and we call this an original reference
an unaltered reference and you have
these patterns for deletion where you
sort of have this gap that's respective
of their being sequence in one and not
the other sample insertions are as you'd
expect the opposite you have tandem
duplications that because they're
they're duplicated you have a region of
overlap right because the sequences are
present in twice and one of the samples
you have inversions where you get sort
of this pattern like this because once
you reach the edge of the inversion
you're actually capturing sequence from
the other side and then you have more
complex structures such as deletions and
inversions or duplications and versions
and insertions that are more
representative of complex structural
rearrangements and and what's
interesting about this is that in each
of these cases if you take the original
reference and you know where that
deletion is and you take that reference
and you alter it to include that
deletion then you can see this altered
reference that has now that identity
line that you expect and so this sort of
logic underlies the entire strategy that
we're using here this you give us a
prediction we alter the reference and
then we see how close it looks to that
identity line in the diagonal and so
here's an example if we go back to that
example I gave two slides ago and we see
this again this this weird structure
with three deletions in a translocation
if we do take a single long read we
build a dot bot against the reference of
this location and what you see here is
is these sort of again these blocks
where you have these you have these
deletions between segments but then you
sort of have this rearrangement where
instead of being a straight line you
have a piece here a piece here that's a
respective of that that that
translocation and so if we take the
prediction that first SV color
prediction and we change the reference
to match that and now we align that back
to that long read using a dot bot and
you clearly see
that diagonal line that's now consistent
with these structures and so how we do
this is actually fairly simple right
it's this idea that so our approach is
named vapor and essentially the way it
works is we take these structures we
take a create a score around how the
unaltered reference is it gives the long
read at this location right and so we go
through and we check where all these
points are relative to this vertical
line and we use actual instead of doing
total distance to the line like a
Euclidean distance we look at vertical
distance then kisses a little bit
there's a number of reasons for this I
won't get into but it's a tends to be a
bit more robust and essentially we go
through every point on this position so
in this case one to n naught where n
naught is the number of points and we
calculate the absolute distance between
this and we come up with a score or the
original plot and we can do the same
thing for the altered reference right
the idea being here that if your
reference is identical or close to
identity your score is essentially going
to be zero and so we can use this to
calculate a REIT or for an individual
read by taking the ratio of the score of
the original structure relative to the
predicted structure and and then
subtracting one because we found that
that works pretty well they stopped up
the downstream distributions and and
then at the end of the day we can say
well if the reads four ends up being
larger than zero then we can assert that
the predicted structure is supported by
the read and if it's not then the
original structure is better supported
by three it's a fairly simple model here
but it works quite well one of the
limitations of this is that there are
very large structural variations that
are longer than the size of a file read
of the long read that you're using and
so in this case we can't traverse the
entire reading and instead we focus on
reads that cross the predicted
breakpoints and we do a similar type of
approach in this case we actually allow
a little bit of error off of the
diagonal but it's the same sort of
strategy where we're comparing the
distance of the diagonal from the
original structure and
the predicted structure so if we put all
this together we have our pipeline here
and looks like some of these these
slides didn't come through as long on
apologize for that but essentially we
look at an input VCF file that has the
predicted structural variance in it we
we first actually look at that locus in
the reference and we sort of take the
reference against itself at that
position and we perform a QC check
because there's there's many places in
the genome where even with long reads
it's not amenable to this type of
analysis perhaps it's an entire stretch
of tendon tandem repeats and so we have
a step where we we start with a K value
of 10 but essentially what we do is
we'll we'll increase that K value and
this will decrease the number of dots
that we have and that's a resolution for
for validating these structures but we
can sort of clean up some of the noise
with longer Kaymer's and when we try
this over and over again until we have a
clean enough of a plot that we feel we
can do something with if we can't then
we sort of just a label something is not
accessible move on but if we can do we
go through and we decide how many reads
holy spam through the variance if there
aren't enough then we looked at the
individual break points and then we we
calculate scores as I previously
described so how does this work
well it works pretty well actually and
what we we try to assess the efficacy of
this approach in terms of how people
would actually use PacBio
you know in this case you know we go
from a read depth of two all the way up
to seventy seventy cover X coverage pack
file is fairly expensive and it's not
really scalable at this point so in our
thoughts that someone may or group may
want to do a low pass or a targeted
PacBio over regions of interest and we
wanted to see how well our approach
works these different levels read them
and so what were you what we're showing
here our receiver operator curves for
different read depths and we see that
once we get up passed around ten
coverage on a set of simulated
structural variants where we know the
the truth
have been false positive also we have
around a 96% area under the curve which
is pretty good and of course once you go
up to 20 it's almost 100 percent
accurate and so for heterozygous events
we do we do very well and as you might
expect we do them better for homozygous
events where we sort of simulated you
know events that are current both
chromosomes and therefore everybody read
that that look at that locus should
should support that variant we also took
a look at complex structural variants
and these are a little trickier these
are the you know inverted plus deleted
plus duplicated the ones that have
multiple bright points and we don't do
quite as well in these regions but even
then at high coverage we start to
recapitulate the the vast majority of
the calls and even so even at lower
coverage you can do fairly well at a
little false discovered right with just
acknowledging that we're not able to
assess all the calls so we wanted to
assess our caller on real data and we
use the thousand genomes base three
calls for five samples in terms of how
well we do in these regions these are
samples that have long read available
for them as well as a high quality call
set and essentially what we did is we
used the we use true calls on chromosome
1 and then we lifted those coordinates
over to chromosome 2 the service sort of
the negative control since there's no
reason that the coordinates are
independent the chromosomes are
independent and so it's just a quick way
of of assessing our false our false
positive rate are false validation rate
and and what we find is that depending
on our score cutoff that we use we can
actually really like our validation
rates extremely high for for deletions
it's a little lower for insertions but
it's still quite quite respectable and
then for inversions
it's when the numbers for the inversions
are actually fairly small because there
aren't as meeting the set but it doesn't
pay for inversions and we're still
looking at improving that and then here
of course the
the important regions false discovery
rate the false validation rate in this
case is actually low or from any of
these as well and so for almost all of
this and so that's that's good basically
paper validates a call it's probably
right next we looked at break point
accuracy these different colors use
depending on whether using read depth or
you're using you know paradin type
approaches your accuracy on where the
specific break point for the variant can
vary and so we wanted to see how robust
our validation was if it only works when
you have exact breakpoints aren't there
some flexibility depending on the color
and what we find is actually we our
validation rate remains it of course is
the highest when the break points are
exact but as you move away from the
break points for both deletions and
insertions we do have some flexibility
up to about 50 base pairs on each
direction that will still it may not
have as high of a validation score but
it will still be considered validated as
as capturing some real signal and so
that that's comforting that we can
handle the flexibilities from these espy
colors and not invalidate something
that's a real event but it's just off
from the break points by certain Oh
finally we looked at our ability to
genotype and this is again using the
thousand genomes base 3a structure
variation genotypes and you know so so
another important aspect is not just
whether or not a variant is real but
whether it's being called real you know
in terms of whether it's one copy or two
in the genome and so what we show here
is that our vapor score actually tracks
very well as a spore with whether
something is a heterozygous event or a
homozygous alternative allele and so the
vapor score is sort of a proxy for
genotype in this respect and you can use
that to sort of guide whether or not the
underlying phenotypes that are reported
are accurate so we've been using this in
a number of different manners one of the
ways we've used it and this is just one
of many approaches that are that have
been used to assess these different
colors is sort of
looking at structural variations is
detected as the human genome structure
variation consortium and so you know
going through and figuring out which
these combinations are calling accurate
structural variants and what we were
also using it to determine whether or
not there's particular subsets of
algorithms that might be optimal or
capturing a larger degree of real a real
variance so so that's a tool for
assessing structural variation but but
but many of these short read collars as
I said at the beginning of the
presentation are still limited in their
ability to find evidence in highly
repetitive regions these are regions
that the paper doesn't validate and
we've seen this consistently and so we
developed an approach called Palmer to
dig into this and this is work done by a
postdoc in my lab like enshou and this
is awesome collaboration with others
here at the University of Michigan
including Jeff Kidd John Moran and
Kenneth Quan and there's a manuscript
preparation should be up on the by
archive here and then your feature and
so as a bit of background we're looking
at things that fall inside a repeats
it's been know exactly what these
repeats are and in many cases these are
these repeats of stem from transpose
wall elements which are DNA sequences
which can sort of copy or cut and paste
some regions of the genomes to others
they're off the term repetitive elements
and as I said before about 44% of the
genome is made up of typically remnants
of these repeats that have moved and
then there's a subset of these code
rental transposons that that work
through an RNA intermediate and a
similar mechanism to retroviruses and
I'm actually going to focus on one
particular class of this for now this is
a minor element and so line ones are
youing even though the bolts referred to
as l1 HS make up about 17% of the genome
they mobilized through a copy-paste
mechanism from a small number of active
units the full-length elements are 6 KB
in length but due to the reverse
transcriptase mechanism by which they
integrate back into the genome they
typically are truncated at the by prime
end so
often much smaller than 6 kv these these
elements can take to open reading frames
and are bounded by target size
duplications while also containing a
poly a tail from from that from their
initial transcription from their origin
copy and so we thought the first thing
we were curious about were well if we're
looking for variants inside repeat you
know we're probably missing a lot but in
particular the hardest class is probably
going to be repeats that jump inside a
repeats these are often called nested
and there's been quite a few studies
over the last 10 15 years that have
tried to identify the number of l1 HS
insertions and human samples and the you
know there's been a number of different
insertion rates that have been that have
been tossed around and really all of
them are sort of missing because of the
the methods are the menus have been
missing any insertions that fall on this
44 percent of the genome right and so
one of the things that we found
interesting is that there's really no
current method for specifically calling
el NHS using third-generation
long range DNA sequencing there are a
few methods such as melt that that
includes some support for this but the
but for specifically calling these line
insertions there there aren't as many
tools as there are for example
structural radiation so we decided to
use a very well known sample gm12878
this has been around since the hapmap
project thousand genomes project it was
the focus sample for genome in a bottle
so there's been a lot of a lot of
resources have been generated for the
sample and this this individual is a
female as a member of a 17 individual
pedigree genome in a bottle for example
created 300 X Illumina paired-end the
genomics data exome sequencing solid
there's also a great degree of PacBio
sequence that has been developed to
drive for the sample both from the
genome and final project and also
Washington University in st. Louis as
part of the reference projects and so
this seemed like a good sample
to test and develop our approach on and
our goals are basically to ask the
following questions what might be missed
by the current chart week technologies
this could be a potential effects of
transduction which is when a repeat
copies itself along with surrounding
sequence and inserts itself elsewhere in
the genome and so that that transduce
sequence often looks like the
duplication and then also insertions and
repetitive regions and then also to
looked at refining false negative rates
from current approaches and then can we
use this set of you know can we can we
go and find things that were missed and
then can we use this to help go back and
optimize on short read methods and are
there any new insights that we can learn
regarding the the mechanism preferences
of these elements that may have been
missed and so to do this we developed an
approach called Palmer and here's sort
of a flowchart of how it works I'm not
really going to walk through this
because I'm going to step through a
couple slides talking about key elements
of this but the primary thing that
Palmer does that's perhaps I don't know
if it's novel but it's it's it's the key
strategy to what we're doing is this
idea that we do what we call as a pre
masking step and essentially we take a
reference genome say for example the the
human HS 3075 that was used by the
thousand genomes project and this
contains various repeats that are shown
in green here on the screen and
essentially what happens as we take our
long reads and we line them to the
reference using a common pack file item
like blazer are some of the newer
methods and we observed where they
overlap with these known repeats and
instead of just doing though a blanket
masking of repeats and the reads and
selves which would mask what we're
looking for we instead do a reference
guided masking where if a portion of a
read overlaps a known repeat we mask it
out in that read and so the idea here
then is that anything that's left in the
read after this masking that looks like
a repeat is potentially a novel
insertion and so after we do this we we
identify these these reads that have a
signal we basically do a pairwise
alignment to lnh s sort of a model
sequence for LMH
so we identify reads that that have this
sequence even after masking there were
no reference and we go through we look
for different characteristics of what a
true retro element Ln HS sequence looks
like and so two major aspects of that
are poly a tails and target sight
duplications due to the T PRP sort of
integration strategy of how retro
elements integrate back into the genome
they often create small duplications of
the insertion site but now found the
element we call these target site
duplications and tend to be either
identical are close and identity they
can range from five to 50 base pairs
plus in terms of their size and so in
this particular case we're using this L
1 9 0 8 8.1
reference sequence for LM HS and we've
identified places of reads that have
this and then we go through a research
for a poly a tail and we search for
target site duplications we compare
these targets like duplications to each
other to you know identify places that
might not be under person identical that
are perhaps a single mismatch away and
again we have some cut-offs on how we
determine whether or not these are real
you know if you use too short or
cut-offs the the generous e of the you
know the genetic code it'll just you
know you're gonna find some things a
chance we found greater than 5 base
pairs works fairly well for this we also
go through we look again for the poly a
tail and any sort of transduce sequence
you know ideally a transduced sequence
might actually have an additional poly a
tail from the original copy that was
copied that was transcribed out and so
you can get these more complex
structures within these reads and so
we've modelled that as well finally we
go through and since we do this on an
individual read by read basis we need to
go back and identify regions of the
genome that have multiple reads that
we've captured these signals from and if
we observe this then we can assert that
there's an insertion call about location
finally this is more of a depending on
the sequence that you're using if using
PacBio circular consensus sequences this
min
he is necessary if you're going from the
raw read alignments from the sub reads
one of the approaches we've done it was
to use a local act bio liner called
canoe to do error correction and simply
of leads at a location and this allows
us to have a we do this as a second pass
where we essentially identify lotuses
low-side that we can have an insertion
and then we step back and we say well
let's take all the reads though that we
feel have some support for read and then
we'll assemble them into higher-quality
sequences and then we can get a much
better idea of the length of the
targeted duplications a link to impala
detail and so forth and then we do a
second pass of palmer to precisely
define these features and these
sequences and so we ran this on one two
eight seven eight and after error
correction local assembly and and some
manual validation believe we've looked
at pretty much all of these manually and
we came up with a set of 199 l NHS calls
that that we feel are true and some of
these numbers look like they are wrong
on here so it's really not cool for its
199 but but in general you can see that
they're they're pretty prevalent
throughout the genome we find 50 full
length line insertions 24 insertions and
repetitive regions 42 that have some
evidence twin priming that is a
different mechanism by which when lines
are integrating into the genome there's
sort of a template switching where you
get sort of an inverted sequence at the
five prime end that looks like a line
element of course making things even
more complex and 13 with transduction
sequence so this to us is like a very
nice repertoire of
how many L NHS calls are in this
particular sample the question then
becomes how how real or in it and so we
took a threefold approach to validating
these and the first were to make use of
existing positive clones so Bosmans are
typically 40 KB fragments of sequence
that have been sequenced with Sanger
sequencing or other sequencing
technologies at the three prime end
there's a number of studies in 2007 that
was made by the necklace group that
created this great nice work
pause meds and so the idea since they're
40 KB in size if we find regions that
bound our predicted insertion we should
expect to see a difference in the reads
cluster the read lengths sort of akin to
how we do parent sequencing are paired
in sequencing for deletions and so forth
and indeed what we see if we look
through all of our calls we find there
76 that have paired in support that is
when we look at the distribution of the
insert size we see clustering around
36,000 35,000 this is consistent with
the 5,000 based parents ershon and
sequence because that 35,000 or 34,000
plus a 6 kb insertion would give you the
40 can be expected Bosman insert size
and we found nine sequences that were at
the ends of these husband's that had
direct support for the insertion
typified so so this is sort of direct
orthogonal validation of some of these
calls another approach was we were
interested to say you know how about you
know are there any signatures of our
insertions in the short read WTS data
and so for example even if you have a
repeat inside of a repeat if you have a
line now one HS element that inserted
into another l nhsn sequence that's
identical to it there still would be a
unique junction around that that
insertion point specifically around the
5-prime it now the three prime end has
poly a tails and there's homopolymers
sequences and so it's more difficult so
we focus on the five prime and we took
the 13 base pair fragment from the L
from the 5 prime end of the L NHS that
we predicted in the surrounding region
for a full length of 26 base pairs and
we essentially did came our searches
through the raw fast queue reads in the
number of samples and since we have the
family structure for this one two eight
seven eight we are able to look at the
parents to see how much support we had
for each of these and so far over 199 we
were able to find 178 that had support
for these k-mers in 1 2 8 7 8 and when
we look at the parents there were 102 of
those that we observed at least at the
heterozygous level both parents there
were 38 that we found
father only 37 that we found in the
mother only and only one that we found
specific to the sample and this this
could be a false positive this could
also be and they know who event and so
we can't really rule out either those we
also looked at simulated it so basically
we would take the five prime end of our
predicted line insertion and we would
randomly put it in places in the genome
and see how many insertion points
assuming that was the insertion point
how much that we would observe in these
sequences and for the vast majority of
these we found less than one either zero
or one in most of our simulated sets
which is why you have like the point 1 1
and so forth and so this this suggests
that we're not just picking up k-mers by
chance that have a repeat sequence in
them but we're specifically finding
these be specific by prime ends of these
calls and of course none of these none
of these real events were observed in
the gene and the reference genome as
well I should know we also looked at 10x
genomics data but we have haplotype
specificity for some of these calls and
we were able to read the pitch 90
although this was a lower coverage and
so that that's explain why we're not
fighting with me so this adds quite a
bit of support that are called a rule as
well and then of course you know you
don't trust anything unless it has some
molecular work and so just kids lab in
particular is there Emory I went through
and did some some PCR of our expected
legions PCR is a little tricky because
these are regions that are in and around
repeats and so we've had some trouble
you know getting getting bands for even
though the reference allele on these
were these locations but we were able to
validate four out of six that we
attempted and three of those are novel
that is they they've not been described
before and so we're you know so we have
some it's not a large amount for 199 but
coupled with the other other validation
efforts we feel this suggests that our
our set is quite high quality and so the
next step now is to say well we have 199
we found at by oh how how have other
approaches to call el NHS how successful
have they been relative descent and so
again given this this high degree of
this high degree of resources available
for the sample we were able to look at
just sort of standard you know 50x high
C whole genome shotgun sequencing data
we used a large PacBio sample that we
use to sort of create our 199 and then
we also used a three prime l1 capture
method that was that was described and
discount at all back in 2010 I think and
was was has been refined by Dan flashed
it was a PhD student in Cameron's lab
and we basically ran through these and
we for the whole genome sequence data we
use melt which is a very high quality
mobile element collar we've had a lot of
a lot of good results for melt and we've
already described how we call that
Palmer calls and then we have this sort
of a pipeline for clustering these three
prime reads and so the melt call called
141 calls and the capture 128 calls
effectively so we look at the VIN
diagram of these it looks like this and
you see that there's quite a few our
only calls packed by only calls that are
that are missed by these other other
other samples and the number here in
parentheses are the the fraction of
calls that that after manual inspection
validation came or Counting we feel are
real and since our PacBio sets already
refined of course the vast majority of
those we feel are real so that's why the
numbers are the same but of the the nub
calls the the 26 that we called that
were metal specific our Illumina
specific and terminals of the platform
we fell only five of those were real
I'll describe some of those in a few
slides why that's the case
and then none of the l1 capture method
that were which again was only 10 but we
could do any of those through so so
we're actually finding quite a bit more
with that file than these other samples
if we look down below and we break down
what are we finding by these
intersections and not surprising the
vast majority of the PacBio only are
caPSURE calls all online samples by that
as you can see by that sort of orange
red line there and are the green lines
as well and this is in contrast to the
WGS methods which have almost completely
filtered that out so I'm looking at that
left panel here under beam and on the
right you see this sort of you know
breakdown by intergenic and intronic you
know typically these are you know
roughly the same as you would expect for
most of these but we are finding more
energetic calls with with the path dial
and pop loud pop shooting next we went
back and we looked at if we took this
sort of so so we can we can take this is
this Venn diagram and we can actually
create sort of a gold standard from this
if we take the power calls and we add to
them the five and the three melt and
capture calls we fill our real we can
come up with a set of two hundred and
seven events that we think are real in
this sample so we call this our gold
standards and if we look at all these
combined and that's the all here in this
sort of red orange color and we looked
at the distribution of the pack pile
only calls and we see that they actually
follow very similar distributions of
pack pile is that sort of course
included in the all so you know that
there is a sort of bias here but but but
they follow the same same sort of
distributions that you would expect and
so on the Left panel here we're showing
the length of the lnh s and as I said
before a lot of these are truncated so
so many of these are less than two KB in
length however you see this large spike
at the end of things of events that are
6 KB so these are full length insertions
and so in our entire Saturday identified
40 of these the transduction sequence
lines so for those that carried sequence
with them from there they're the place
in the genome where they were copied
these vary from very small to sometimes
abdominals 3 KB in length we looked at
the targets at duplication lengths begin
keeping the mind we have this hard
cutoff of 5 and and there there's a
there is a spike at 6 and some of these
may not be real but but there's this
very nice distribution where we see 10
12 15 and some even up towards a 25 and
so these are you know sequences that are
these insertions that have almost
complete identity to each other and in
you know the people in the field these
are these are really sort of the
hallmark of a true insertion so so why
are some of the calls and WTS being this
well this is an example of a call that
was found in WGS and that in the
Illumina sequencing said I should call
it aluminum the Illumina sequencing the
shortly data sets and what ends up
happening is there's a tea rich region
that sort of shifts around some of the
some of the reads and creates misleading
sequences that are inferred to be a poly
a tail of a mobile element and if you
look at the pack batteries at the bottom
you can see that really know that
there's really no signals here
indicative of an insertion sequence and
so homo polymer runs repeats as you
might expect do cause do hinder the
ability of short read colors to find
these regions here's an example of
Palmer specific call and so this
actually falls in a existing repeats in
l1 pa3 and if you actually look at the
the Illumina data you see sort of some
signals of truncation of this region of
those little red red lines at that at
that insertion location that are showing
that some of this read is actually
lining somewhere else in the genome but
because of its present in a repeat
because of the uncertainties in these
alignments this was not called as
insertion and again continued
considering that most of these shortly
colors just filter out anything that
falls in a region such as LMP a3 in the
first place
you know that's not surprising but we
can clearly see sort of the the the
truncation of the reads in the PacBio
sequence that are that that are
consistent with an assertion here this
is another pack file called a Palmer
specific call and again this is
something that was not found by the
Illumina data per se the short read data
again falling within a line repeat
region but but in this particular case
if we if we go into the 10x data that we
have for these samples and we use their
labels for haplotype one and haplotype
two we do see a clear signal here for
how
type 1 for this insertion now these are
signals at the great points these are
these split leads in the category split
reads for a prediction but we don't have
any sort of parrot in support that's
required by a lot of these callers again
supporting this idea that the signals
are there they're just not
indistinguishable from from noise
because of these these repeats I'm in
these regions and so this is another
area that the longer in series was fine
this is another interesting example here
that we found so we identified a Annelle
when they just region in the hla region
and so this was of course not cold by
any of the short rains or capture that
that's because of the complexity of HIV
gene but a chilly region we found this
insertion and while when we are
attempting to validate whether it was
real or not we actually looked at some
of the alternative haplotype reference
contains at that location and haplotype
6 in fact contains this insertion and so
it's not really novel per se but given
that the original alignments were
against the the reference allele not
this particular haplotype it does show
sort of our ability to find lying
insertion in complicated regions such as
of HLA finally we decided to look at our
ability to capture and identify mobile
elements from single cell data so this
is a single cell sequencing is really
becoming more and more prevalent as the
different whole genome cab capture
methods have have evolved you know
there's malefactors MVA in this
particular case we're using MD amplified
single cells from one two eight seven
eight since we know sort of what the
background should be from this this gold
standard set we put together and we
compared it to this amplified set we did
whole genome sequencing on this
amplified library we also did this a
single cell whole whole whole genome
capture this three time LM capture and
we actually see a lot of those calls are
missed here and we were a little
surprised by this because we felt that
the blue would have similar similar
calling rate from just the standard
Illumina
library and so we dug into this further
and we sequenced three additional single
cells and so we have four single cell
amplified whole genome sequences in
total and so what I'm showing here is an
upset plot with each of the categories
being the the number of calls on the
left from each of the single sounds
using belt as well as our gold standard
set at 207 and what we find is the gold
standard set by itself has a hundred and
thirty-six calls that's represented of
that large bar on the left so 136 calls
that are missed out of the 207 that we
feel a real in the sample and then these
next columns here show calls that are
specific to each of these single selves
and and it was interesting to us that
this repertoire of mobile elements are
called by individual single cells are
different and so you know this could
very well be do the amplification bias
at with how the displacements occurring
at the genomic level it's possible
there's some issues around repetitive
sequences that are amplifying some
regions higher than others but but it
was kind of striking the difference in
these different single cells where some
found 79 insertions that that were
missed by every other approach and are
likely not to be real since they're not
in our gold standard set while one cell
looked like it did really well and only
have two potential false positives we
see this middle category here where if
we look at combinations between overlaps
with our gold standard set by the single
thousand and we see there are quite a
few calls that are we recapitulate that
are found in our gold standard set but
there's very few that there's only two
calls that were found in every single
single cell amplified genomic sequence
data that were also our gold standard
and the rest were found in either three
or less of the cells and then this is I
guess some accompanying as there are no
no calls that were found by more than
one single cell that were not in our
gold standard set and so this suggests
that again to Mike Lee we missed
anything but but this is sort of support
stuff so our current efforts are our
palmer algorithm right now is
specifically designed for Alan
jes events where we have our software up
on our github I think there should be a
link for that somewhere in this
presentation but we currently have some
data support for a u.s. J's and other
types of variation we're looking at
extending this for general structure
variation such as deletions duplications
you know we're looking to apply this to
some of the other ongoing sequencing
studies using long reads such as genome
in a bottle and interestingly you know
one of the thoughts that we see from
this is that we're actually able to
interrogate those five prime ends of
these transposons in the short read data
set and so what we'd like to do is go
back retro actively on cause that we
find with these long reads and look at
these shortened data sets to see what we
left so so in summary and as you might
expect longer reads would enable the
accurate assessment of structuration and
complex imperative regions they can
allow the detection of nested variation
and allow for better estimate of retro
element insertion rates particularly at
the singles o level and that profiles
derived from longer reads whole promise
for Regina typing cryptic ESPYs and
larger shortly data sets so with that
I'd like to acknowledge my lab in
particular chiffon who did a lot of this
work as well as Arthur the Kid lab in
the Moran lab who helped generate some
of the data for this and of course my
funding so thank you thank you dr. Mills
for that informative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started our first
question is given that many of the novel
insertions you described are in
pre-existing repeats what is the
potential that they may result in an
observable functional effect in cells so
that's been a long-standing question
right in terms of you know our repeats
functional did they play a role or they
his junk or dark matter of the genome
and I think there's where more and more
starting to realize that these are
actually can play important functional
rows there's been a number of papers
recently that in fact that Lou Belski
and Olinsky showed earlier this year
that sequence enriched and aloo elements
actually drive the new Kia legal because
localization of long non-coding RNAs
maikovskis group recently recorded an
sba element insertion in the intron TAF
that can cause x-linked dystonia
parkinsonism and another group showed an
intron and galician can actually create
a alternative splicing and so and this
isn't just for germline either there's
somatic events where a group recently
showed that insertions into existing
insertions can actually modulate gene
expression so so I think we're just
scratching the surface of how you know
what about how relevant these types of
events are and I think having a full
repertoire where they're at and you know
cataloging that is a first step to
understanding that our next question is
will these approaches work with emerging
Longreach technologies such as nanopore
sequencing from Oxford Oxford nanopore
yeah so we haven't actually tested our
approach with Oxford nanopore yet it's
something we are eager to do I think
from a general strategy there's no
reason they should work however you know
there's different models involved and so
one of the things we're looking at
actually there is the recent Jane a tall
paper that did the whole genome assembly
one two eight seven eight and so that
was just published I think a couple
weeks ago and so you know we're we're
really interested in dig into that some
data and see if we see additional
support for insertions see if there
stuff that we might have missed the pack
pile
you know perhaps Oxford nanopore is
better at calling these types of events
so it we're definitely interested in
looking at this further and dr. males it
looks like we have time for one more
question
PacBio is still quite expensive and the
majority of whole genome sequencing is
being done with short read Illumina data
where do you see the best application of
these of these approaches so I think the
I mean of course we're not going to be
doing long read at scale anytime soon
right it's clear that you know there's
we're either over a million or probably
getting close to a million Illumina
sequence denotes here at this point and
so we're not gonna go back and redo
everything with longer I think the
biggest contribution that these types of
that these types of approaches do is
sort of as I said before is like going
back retroactively leaving sets now that
we know that there's a repeat in this
repeat can we go back to be sets and see
how many is an admin right you know it
won't be per se directed discovery but
it essentially genotyping events that
were able to find with newer and better
technologies on these shortly data sets
and so I think that's a clear
application to to the types of stuff
that we've been working on and some of
the things that we've been learning from
these these long reads that we haven't
been able to learn from the short data
sets I would like to once again thank
dr. Mells for his presentation I would
also like to think laborat speaking
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I would like to remind
everyone that today's webcast will be
available on demand mist of 2018 you
receive an email from laborat letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye